Fäll der Name Dubai kommen den meisten
von euch vermutlich direkt solche Bilder
in den Kopf hohe Wolkenkratzer reiche
Menschen schnelle Autos tolle Hotels und
vieles mehr in den letzten 30 Jahren ist
Dubai rasant gewachsen der Tourismus
boomt und immer mehr Geschäftsleute
verlagern ihren Wohnsitz nach Dubai doch
keineswegs ins alte Dubai hier im
Fischerdorf hat irgendwann mal alles
angefangen das Geld sitzt heute
allerdings ganz wo anders und Stadtteile
wie Dubai dera verfallen im Vergleich
zum Rest der megaacity in Armut ich
wollte unbedingt herausfinden wie sieht
es in den Stadtteilen aus die es nicht
in die typischen tourismuswerbe schaffen
und habe mich auf den Weg gemacht und
damit Leute einen wunderschönen guten
Morgen aus meinem Hotelzimmer in Dubai
ich bin hier gerade mitten auf dieser
Palme ich zeige euch mal ein Foto wo ich
mich gerade ungefähr befinde heute ist
auf jeden Fall die Sicht auch ein
bisschen besser und ich habe direkt ein
Ausblick auf das Burch alarab Hotel und
gleicht kann man auch den Burch Khalifa
sehen also das höchste Gebäude der Welt
da war ich noch gar nicht wir werden da
heute auch kurz mal lang fahren ich habe
mir heute was ganz Spezielles überlegt
wir werden uns natürlich ein bisschen
Dub anschauen aber nicht das was man so
kennt weil ich glaube die meisten wenn
man Dub hört hört denkt man okay protzig
hohe Häuser alles teuer teure Autos
alles sieht hochwertig aus da leben nur
reiche Menschen und so weiter und so
fort und bevor ich irgendwie stumpf
solche Sachen getestet hätte die
unfassbar viel Geld kosten dachte ich
mir ich möchte mich auch mal mit anderen
Sachen beschäftigen ich habe ein
bisschen recherchiert und wir fahren
heute mal in die armen Gegenden von
Dubai bin ja zum ersten Mal hier und
werde euch im Laufe des Videos auch so
ein bisschen meinen Eindruck von Dubai
vermitteln wie jetzt so die letzten Tage
waren was ich von dube halte ich denke
es wird ein ereignisreicher Tag und ich
freue mich schon muss jetzt erstmal hier
Auschecken weil ich das Hotel wieder
wech Leute bis
[Musik]
später ich denke ihr habt schon
mitbekommen ich befinde mich hier
aktuell in Dubai es sieht aber gar nicht
so typisch Dubai mäßig aus zumindest an
dem Ort wo ich jetzt gerade bin auf
jeden Fall bin ich mittlerweile schon
vier Tage hier und konnte mir so einen
ersten Eindruck von Dubai verschaffen
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich anfangen soll
also ich persönlich bin auf jeden Fall
ein Mensch ich mag so alte Städte und wo
man wirklich sieht hier steckt Kultur
hinter hier leben schon seit
Jahrtausenden Menschen und das hat für
mich dann immer so einen zusätzlichen
Wohlfühlcharakter wenn man halt an dem
Ort ist keine Frage Dubai ist super
imposant und gerade durch diese hohen
Hochhäuser die wirklich teilweise sehr
sehr hoch sind ist das ganze schon sehr
sehr Eindrucks voll und ich bin auf
jeden Fall froh dass ich jetzt mal hier
gewesen bin und das gesehen habe mein
letztes Hotel war auf dieser künstlich
angelegten Palme da war ich auch abends
zweimal unterwegs und oftmals fehlt mir
da halt irgendwie so der Charakter und
man guckt sich das so an und denkt sich
Alter das sieht alles so künstlich aus
also zusammengfasst zum Wohnen wäre das
auf jeden Fall nicht für mich und ich
bin jetzt auch ein bisschen überrascht
ich bin jetzt hier nach Dubai dera
gefahren das hier ist die Altstadt oder
das alte Dubai und durch das
Wirtschaftswachstum und die ganzen
ausländischen Leute die hingezogen sind
um irgendwie beruflich Erfolg zu haben
oder was weiß ich sammelt sich das Geld
halt in Downtown wo auch der Bursch
Khalifa ist oder halt am Dubai Marina
dort wo sich dann halt diese Palme
befindet und dieser Stadtteil verarmt in
Anführungsstrichen für Dubai
Verhältnisse komplett hier leben
natürlich super viele von diesen
Gastarbeitern und ich fand das super
interessant weil das Bild was die
meisten Deutschen von Dubai haben ist ja
wirklich dass es überall nur diese hohen
Gebäude gibt luxuspur Reichtum und so
weiter und so fort und ich wollte mir
wenn ich schon hier bin auch einfach mal
ein Eindruck verschaffen wie Dubai sonst
noch so aussehen kann und euch das so
ein bisschen zeigen ich bin echt mal
gespannt und wir gehen mal los und ja
mal schauen was ich so hier in Dubai
dera erleben werden was mir aber auch
wichtig war zu sagen euch einmal so die
Vorteile aufzuzeigen die ich auf jeden
Fall jetzt hier in den letzten Tagen
gemerkt habe und man muss einfach sagen
Dubai ist eine unfassbar sichere und
saubere Stadt also das merkt man richtig
heftig man braucht überhaupt keine
Sorgen machen dass man irgendwo
ausgeraubt wird oder dass das Handy
geklaut wird ich war beispielsweise
gestern Abend in bar oder so und du
kannst einfach dein iPhone darumleegen
lassen auf Klo gehen das interessiert
keinen Menschen also es ist wirklich
unfassbar sicher das wäre echt richtig
geil wenn das in Deutschland auch
überall so wäre der Sicherheitsaspekt
ist natürlich ein unschlagbarer Vorteil
hinzu kommt noch das tolle Wetter die
Sonne scheint hier durchschnittlich fast
9 Stunden pro Tag und die Temperaturen
bewegen sich das Jahr über zwischen 27
und 45°. außerdem ist das Essensangebot
in Dubai unschlagbar es gibt viele
internationale Fastfoodketten und in
Restaurants wird man was den Geschmack
und Qualität angeht so gut wie nie
enttäuscht die Karim App steuert alle
möglichen Dienstleistungen wie essen
taxiärzte und das ist super praktisch
man braucht halt nur eine App ich konnte
beispielsweise rund um die Uhr Burger
von shak Shu bestellen absolut
geisteskrank in dera gibt es auch den
berühmten goldzug ein der ältesten und
traditionellsten Märkte des Emirats hier
gibt es alles mögliche von Schmuck über
Gewürze bis hin zu Fußballtrikot und auf
meinem Weg ins richtige Leben von dera
bin ich einmal durchgehuscht no no F
thank you ach so und das wurde mir auch
gesagt hier gibt's halt super viel so
Gewürze und sowas riecht man
auch
k okay es ist ein bisschen wie in in der
Türkei da war ich ja auch einmal in
Istanbul in Istanbul auf dem Basar da
wird man auch so viel angequatscht aber
na ja hier fehlt mir das Dortmund Trikot
W Bria Dortmund Dortmund Dortmund
dortmundin ich bin ich ah okay bye
bye ja bei dir ich dich
auch okay ich würde aber mal sagen der
Markt jetzt hier hinter mir war schon
auch ein bisschen touristischer und noch
nicht so das was ich jetzt genau sehen
wollte aber ganz lustig ich habe noch
nie so viele Gewürze gleichzeitig in der
Nase gehabt wie da jetzt gerade wir
gehen auf jeden Fall mal weiter in diese
Richtung also ich glaube je weiter man
dahin kommt desto mehr sieht man halt
auch so dieses typische leben und nicht
halt einfach nur diesen Luxus teilweise
auch mehr Schein als Sein das habe ich
auch gemerkt also wir haben schon viele
Leute die hier öfter hinfahren gesagt
Dubai ist teilweise extrem oberflächlich
und da kann ich auch in vielen Bereichen
nur zustimmen thank you Germany alles
gut
dan also die können auf jeden Fall alle
deutsch
hier sch bit okay ich glaube so langsam
komme ich auch weg von diesem
touristischen Gassen Alter warum sind
hier denn so viele taub boah ich hasse
die Dinger bra auf jeden Fall ganz dring
jetzt mal irgendwas zu essen und hier
findet man bestimmt auch so Lokalitäten
irgendwo deswegen schauen wir da
mal auch ganz interessant hier hinter
mir sind z.B jetzt so zwei Geldautomaten
Truck Geldautomaten Trucks na ihr wisst
was ich meine Geldtransporte in
Deutschland haben die auch alle so
Waffen dabei und hier haben die einfach
nur Schlagstöcke das meint auch jemand
den ich gestern hier getroffen habe der
hier halt schon länger lebt die machen
sich halt gar keine Sorgen dass sie
irgendwie überfallen werden weil ja ist
halt 100% sicher oh und Zebrastreifen
gibt's
auch und das einzige was hier recht
preiswert ist ist halt wirklich
Taxifahren sonst Hotels
Lebensunterhaltungskosten zumindest in
den Vierteln wo ich bis jetzt war sind
sind auf jeden Fall deutlich höher als
in Deutschland nur man kann halt
wirklich überall recht gut Taxi
hinfahren ist immer recht günstig und
was ich auch gelernt habe die Taxifahrer
die wohnen halt auch größtenteils
außerhalb also teilweise auch hier
diesem Viertel aber auch noch weiter
außerhalb und die verdienen so zwischen
400 und 500 € umgerechnet im Monat dafür
dass sie aber auch ziemlich viel Taxi
fahren also jeden Tag von morgens bis
abends oder in der Nacht was weiß ich
also wenn man hier so lang läuft wen
wenn ihr jetzt nicht wüsstet wo ich bin
dass das hier Dubai
ist krass ne eigentlich aber gut ist
halt auch eine große stad und ich denke
in jeder Stadt auch so luxuriös wie auch
immer sie sein mag gibt es natürlich
auch solche Viertel ne
und was mir aber auch wichtig ist zu
sagen ich will das hier jetzt nicht als
so ein Ghetto abstempeln oder so es gibt
Länder da gibt es Viertel wo die Armut
viel krasser und intensiver ist aber
wenn man dieses Viertel hier im
Vergleich zu dem Dubai vom Social Media
oder so sieht tiktok was weiß ich da ist
der Kontrast natürlich extrem
ne aber klar hier das sieht will auch
nicht einfach schumpfen so Häuser Filmen
das macht man ja auch nicht aber hier
wohnen auf jeden Fall ziemlich viele
Menschen auf sehr engen Raum und das hat
nichts zu tun mit irgendeinem Penthaus
für 4000 € im Monat
ne Leute zieht euch mal diese Balkone da
oben
rein ich denke daran kann man schon gut
erkennen wie viele Leute da oben
eigentlich in so einer Wohnung
wohnen
ich versuche mir jetzt auf jeden Fall
mal irgendwas zu essen zu besorgen Alter
crazy
hello okay das muss ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt essen hier habe ich jetzt
anscheinend die Fleischstraße
erwischt weil ich möchte natürlich auch
mal wissen was kostet hier eigentlich so
eine Cola oder so wenn man die jetzt in
Downtown oder dort bei der Palme kauft
jumera heißt das ja da bist halt richtig
schnell 3 4 € los wen ich sogar noch
mehr also ich bin auf jeden Fall jetzt
in soem afghanischen Laden glaube ich
bin mal gespannt ist so heiß
ne
[Musik]
so jetzt gibt erstmal was zu essen das
ist auf jeden Fall eine große Portion
wer ich niemals
[Musik]
schaffen das ist richtig nice das hier
ist mir eigentlich sogar zu scharf ich
kann nicht so scharf essen das ist
einfach eine
riesenption so Leute also ohne Scheiß
von dieser Portion hätten wirklich
glaube ich fün Leute satt werden können
Alter ich habe noch nie so eine große
Portion in irgendeinem Restaurant
bekommen das war ja riesig bin jetzt
auch echt satt und ich habe vielleicht
so leid es mir tut nur ein Drittel
geschafft auf jeden Fall hat es jetzt
umgerechnet die Cola 75 Cent gekostet
also wirklich super günstig und das
Essen auch nur knapp 2,50 € also ich
habe nicht mal 3,50 € bezahlt für das
alles zusammen sorry also das ist
wirklich ein Geisteskranker Unterschied
im Vergleich zur anderen Seite halt von
Dubai ne da hätte das auf jeden Fall das
zehnfacher gek
kostet
hey what's up also das muss man wirklich
sagen die Leute hier sind good in
you die Leute hier sind alle super
freundlich also es macht echt Spaß hier
so rumzusteppen ja ich wurde heute
wirklich schon 50 Mal gegrüßt gefragt wo
ich herkomme klar einige wollen auch
dann irgendwie dass ich da was kaufe
aber die meisten hier die einfach so
rumrennen sind total cool anders wie in
Deutschland da wird man immer nur dumm
angeguckt wenn man mit einer Kamera
rumrennt na ja so ist das ne und noch
als kleiner Tipp wenn ihr auch mal nach
Dubi wollt aber keinen Bock habt jeden
Tag 100 oder 150 € für ein Hotel
auszugeben hier in dieser Region gibt es
wohl einige Hotels die echt vernünftig
sind vom Standard her und gar nicht mal
teuer wobei ich das natürlich auch nicht
selber getestet habe sondern nur im
Internet gelesen habe das war's aber
auch noch nicht da hinten geht's noch
weiter ich bin mal gespannt was noch
kommt Alter hier gibt's einfach iPhones
und so alter WTF jung viele das WD mir
auch gesagt dass es hier auf jeden Fall
günstigere Handys gibt also wenn man
hier ein iPhone kauft spart man so 150 €
ich fr mal was ein iPhone 14
kostet
pro iPhone 14
pro in
Germany okay I will maybe I come to you
but okay thank you nice to meet you to
Leute der meinte gerade das iPhone 14
pro ich habe gerade mal eingetippt bei
mir wä umgerechnet unter 1000 € kann
doch eigentlich gar nicht sein oder
kostet das nicht noch mindestens 13 oder
so in Deutschland na ja nur eine Sache
die mir auffällt hier sind super viele
so kleine Katzen und die wirken
irgendwie alle so klein und dünn das ist
also keine Ahnung wie ihr sehen könnt so
langsam wird's auch dunkel hier ich bin
jetzt eigentlich auch komplett aus dera
raus also einmal komplett durchgelaufen
möglich viel glaube ich eingefangen ich
weiß gar nicht ob am Ende da ein cooles
Video raus wird aber ich gebe mir
[Musik]
Mühe
so Leute und hier haben wir jetzt
natürlich das komplette Gegenteil von
der Region wo ich eben war ich bin auch
zum allerersten Mal jetzt gerade hier am
Burch kalalifa ist sehr imposant zu
sehen Essen ist auch ganz gut aber eben
hat es auch lecker geschmeckt ich lass
das so ein bisschen privat hier auf mich
wirken ist auf jeden Fall ganz geil aber
ich wollte jetzt nicht irgendwie ein
Video über teure Sachen in Dubai machen
ich hoffe das Video hat Euch gefallen
ich werde mir jetzt hier heute Abend
noch ein bisschen was angucken aber das
kommt halt nicht in dieses Video weil
darum soll es heute nicht gehen ist auf
jeden Fall ein sehr krasser Kontrast
definitiv danke fürs zuschauen abonniert
sehr sehr gerne den Kanal und wir sehen
uns nächste Woche wieder gibt's ein
neues Video haut rein ciao